I want to say a few words about the
Frankie program in science and
humanities program which is very
generous and helps us it's made possible
by the generosity of Richard and Barbara
psyches this series is named after
Robert Schulman
Shirley professor emeritus of chemistry
molecular biophysics and biochemistry
and senior research scientist and
diagnostic radiology I'm not going to
embarrass him by forcing due to poverty
versus he was a founding fellow of the
with me and an unwavering supporter of
the integration science show
I want to thank Gary Thomasson to give
this marvelous speakers to Nami Thompson
humanity's to mark our senators on goals
to an hour
[Music]
student says I always do this talks go
with a seminar and the students have
been absolutely amazing thinking about
what it means to report on non giving
the worlds as if there were worlds if
there was something called reports from
them we have an incredibly lively
discussion today with clerical workers
our guest tonight in which we
interrogated her and pushed her and she
was gracious enough to push back in all
the right places I want to mention
before I introduce our speaker that on
November 13th when well de Landa is
going to be speaking on a philosophical
chemistry this was a talk that was
postponed over previous day because he
had the flu and if the molecules that
have affected him in the past don't
affect that in the future we'll be
talking about the point of view of
molecules today I want to introduce
Claire Colebrook who is Edward Murrow
sparks profession professor of English
at Penn State University who has held
professorships in unity in Berg and
Sterling University who was a senior
lecturer in philosophy and critical
theory and Monash University all
incredible credentials for a critical
theorist and to mention only a few of
her books which has the biggest range of
anyone I think working today
first of all irony in the work of
philosophy from 2003 Milton evil in
literary history which she doesn't hate
the loose in the meaning of life in 2010
William Blake in digital aesthetics for
2012 we get the idea hey what do you
books and now there are new great honor
this talk I'm gonna give today I'm gonna
try and read it out because I tend to go
off-script and ramble so I'm gonna read
out some written ramble but I'm very
honored to be here and thanks for
inviting me and thanks for the seminar
this afternoon which made me rethink
things to the point where I might not
believe any of what I'm actually going
to read out what I'm going to do
hopefully is connect three concepts art
wait a minute art but I'm gonna say but
art because I can't I can't sustain that
for an hour or less even our fragility
and world and the end of the world so I
guess that's four things so there are
three ways we might think about the end
of the world literally the end of the
world might be the annihilation of the
planet this world this this earth or
even the annihilation of existence a
catastrophe of cosmic proportions that
brings matter substance and not just
what has come to be known as life to an
end there is some literature on
that sort of catastrophe the end of the
world the end of the planet possibly the
end of the cosmos and matter it's that
sense of the world has very little
purchase in the booming end of the world
media industries a booming industry
bandwagon which I just hopped onto I
mean I mean end of world studies so in
terms of a cultural representations of
what that might mean one might think of
Lars von Trier's melancholia as one of
the few films to avoid redemptive
conclusions and to think of the end of
the world as the end of the planet maybe
there are some other examples out there
if maybe Byron's darkness as a text
about annihilation as such not just what
the second sense which is what I'm going
to talk about one might think of the end
of the world rather uncritically as the
end of whatever counts as our world
so most apocalyptic or post-apocalyptic
culture is dominated by this sense the
world is not human life and not even
human social life but human life that is
aware of itself as globally human aware
of all the variants cultures spaces and
times that make up the human what do I
mean by that well in post-apocalyptic
culture films but also books the end of
the world is more often than not
depicted as a world where humans have
lost global reflectiveness classic case
would be Cormac McCarthy's the road
where we're left wandering around we
haven't got cameras we haven't got
phones we haven't got televisions so
we're just humans gathered together
wandering around
we've lost the world by wings but by
which I mean we've lost a sense of
viewing the rest of the world or
imagining the rest of the world it's
just us left it's a world without
viewing a world reduced to immediacy or
and here's the point I want to make this
is something it's a world with what
without the
the aesthetic here is a specific mode of
worldly humanity where one is able to
regard objects others and fragments as
signs of another world so that's how I'm
defining the aesthetic I know it's a
problematic probably a lazy way of using
it but it's how I'm going to use it that
the aesthetic is the capacity to view
something as a fragment from another
world it might be worth asking at what
point the human became global in this
aesthetic sense at what point did being
able to view oneself and others as
fragments of an interconnected whole
become definitive of who we are now the
possibility of thinking otherwise other
other than this form of aesthetic
humanity is given over and over again
today in post-apocalyptic culture where
we're imagining that what has come to be
known as the world which is this you
know paintings and fragments from a past
buildings and books that suggest a path
that's all been annihilated and we're
left as the mere beings we are
so typically post-apocalyptic culture
represents the end of the world as the
end of the aesthetic that's one of my
claims typically the future is at once
the end of the world with the typical
loss of imagine ease and leisurely
freedoms but it's also a utopian and
dystopian diagnosis of the present the
threat of climate change which is played
out over and over again in contemporary
culture mainly cinema but also
literature exposes us to a state of
emergency where whether we are like
whether we're slave like replicants or
not the fragility of existence will
threaten everything that we deemed to be
human to take the most recent example
Blade Runner 2049 I don't know how many
people have seen it yeah it's a long
film and I'm one of the idiots that
didn't go and see it in 3d because I
went to the wrong cinema
Bladerunner 2049 imagines the future to
be one in which we have been saved by
synthetic farming methods but where that
technology of redemption has also
enabled corporate control and exposed us
to subjection to those that hold the
power of living on I see that as a
typical post apocalyptic motif where the
fragility of our own existence enables
something like a state of emergency to
seize hold of power and then preclude us
from being properly human by being
properly human I mean being capable of
the aesthetic being not subjected to
mere life so the utopian strand of the
film and I don't think this contains any
spoilers but but by the looks of when I
said who's seen and I didn't see a lot
of enthusiasm so probably not spoiling
it for anyone any rate the utopian
strand of the film lies in a
revolutionary moment movement led by
some replicants who know about the
miracle and that's the word that's used
of a replicant who gave birth somewhere
out there to replicants managed to give
birth even though that's an interesting
opportunity for science fiction the film
doesn't I think you could have had some
interesting theories about how to
replicants managed to replicate but not
they didn't go there they did about it
so what is essentially human the
capacity to generate life is at once no
longer solely human and yet it's this
very capacity of birth and creation that
holds the promise to Futurity in the
film so the film ends as post
apocalyptic films often do including the
film of Cormac McCarthy's wrote with a
child who is not the humanity of the
present but who will be the humanity of
the future the moral axiology of the
narrative is typically post apocalyptic
in the way in which it parses the
relations among humanity world fragility
and creativity so what is that what is
always being destroyed humans are still
in existence
but what our exposure to fragility has
done is remove any capacity of the
aesthetic there's plenty of simulation
there's plenty of copying but creativity
is what's placed under threat and
significantly the redemptive child in
the film is also the creator of dreams I
guess I just did spoiler but probably
you'll forget that I've said that almost
certainly so what I'm trying to suggest
is there's a narrative arc to
post-apocalyptic culture which is very
very common in which humanity as it has
been has destructively just as
destructively has destroyed the world
but humanity as it really is emerges at
the end to save the world and humanity
as it really is is not corporate world
enslaving humanity but this creative
future all and what I will call
aesthetic humanity comes to save the art
will save the day right we're liberated
from mere existence one way of reading
the present would be to see where we are
port where we are as poised on the brink
of fragility that's one way of reading
the present I think it's the way of
reading the present but one way of
reading with the present would be to see
where we are is poised on the brink of
fragility and we might capture this
present by way of the phrase too big to
fail humanity is too big to fail life in
general is a process of coming into
being and passing away emergence and
extinction existence and non-existence
we all know that any of us who are did
grade one primary school science know
things come into being they live they
die right but to say humanity will just
come and go and die come on that's
that's not serious you know we're too
big to fail we we're not we don't just
come into being and pass away what
happens if we start to think about the
end of all relation into coming into it
all relation to coming into being and
passing away that would seem to amount
to the end of the world and that is
unthinkable the world in the sense of a
global awareness of becoming is
I think so encompassing that it simply
must be its non-being is unthinkable or
too big to fail and so I think one of
the performative effects a
post-apocalyptic culture however bleak
we feel about humanity however worthless
we might feel about human history all
you have to do is pose a threat to it in
a disaster epoch and suddenly there's
this no no I know humans are bad but
we're not that bad and you save us at
the save us at the end in some other
redeemed form so if there was simply
existence simply stuff or matter that
did not know itself as matter or did not
take up a relation to itself then that
seems clearly not as worthy of life as
life that knows itself to be so life
comes into being and passes away but the
wonderful thing about human life
supposedly is it knows itself to be
coming into being and passing away so
zombies for example and I know too much
is said about zombies and I'm just going
to add to the too many sentences that
have been other though about zombies but
zombies for example are the end of the
world in so many ways just simply
because they perceive they live but they
don't know that they perceive it or live
so in in many ways we appear to be on
the brink of the end of the world but
what makes us too big to fail such that
our end would not be a minor event but
the event such that the end of our world
would be the end of the world is the way
we have in which we have constructed
ourselves around non failure so we're
too big to fail not not just too big to
fail because we're too important but
that our failure would be the end of all
narratives of progress failure and
success so when we talk of human rights
human dignity
basic human conditions and humanity we
do refer to a specific portion of modern
liberal affluent humanity that
established social forms of freedom and
autonomy because of manufactured
stability so the the creation of a
humanity that is too big and too
important to fail was the outcome of a
long history of manufacturing stability
so we weren't just merely
Cormac MacCarthy type beings wandering
the planet we were beings with a sense
of a world a sense of Futurity and a
sense of a right to be human our climate
our world our sense of self was possible
it possible only by way of a series of
industries that out sourced fragility so
what came to feel of itself as human as
global humanity achieved itself by
outsourcing fragility the history of
slavery would be but one example of that
outsourcing of fragility where other
other humans bore the burden of
vulnerability and fragility in order for
a stable humanity the outside of which
was unthinkable to emerge the only
future we can imagine as desirable is
one where the entire globe becomes human
just like me where what we have now is
sustained and extended where stability
increasingly wins out over fragility
where recognition Trump's chaotic
dispersal non recognition and the end of
the world so the end of the world at
least as it's been figured so far has
always been the end of this global human
relation ality so I take us my classic
image of this Cormac McCarthy's the road
it's the end of the world there are
still humans they may be eating each
other but there are still humans but
what's gone is any form of global
humanity or relationality and certainly
any form of art here's where I go on to
talk about art more specifically art and
its notion and the notion of
relationality in a very unremarkable
sense art is a relational concept
thinking about anything of course
requires relations and there's no
concept that isn't bound up with the
world language and context from which it
emerges even in the hard sciences what
something really is relies upon the ways
in which practices disciplines and other
properties and tendencies form relations
with whatever is in question to define
something is to understand its relations
but to say that thinking speaking and
theorizing something require relations
does not necessarily
reduce everything to relations so
understanding h2o means understanding
its relations and having a relation
towards it but it is it is also in
itself distinct from those relations
maybe even if we only know molecules
through relations we can nevertheless
nevertheless think about the molecular
level this might be why we can say that
relations are external to terms being
short tall near or far is not within the
thing itself but mapped in relation to
what it is two other things I think
that's obvious but this is not to say
that all we have are relations that
generate things if relations are
external then there are some forces that
come into relation now here's my claim
art has an added dimension of
relationality so it's relationality plus
or relationality 2.0 or something art
has an added dimension of relationality
the very just what counts as art depends
on context institutions cultures
language taste and history the very idea
of art as such a separate domain of
objects defined by a certain quality
beauty spirit genius sublimity effect is
almost certainly not Universal I think
that's not a controversial claim but
that the notion of art is not a
universal concept the very notion of a
culture that has art is not a universal
concept where the cave paintings epics
madrigals vases and necklaces that we
now view in galleries thought of created
or experienced as art I'm gonna say no
I'm going to say that things that we now
deemed to be art because we separate
them look at them as fragments of a past
world were not seen that way certainly
things like madrigals stained-glass
windows did not have that quality in
their creation this is where in ways
that a distinct art is in direct
relation with the end of the world the
end of our world and what I will call a
specifically transcendental fragility to
be art something must indicate a world
that is not fully present
world that is not fully ours so to view
something as an art object is to see it
as a fragment of another world so here
we can contrast art objects and the
world they intimate with everyday
objects that are fully within our world
so to take just one example some
instructions arrive with my IKEA sofa I
half read them and fleetingly look at
the diagrams and the pieces I assemble
my agneta sofa and throw the
instructions out with the packaging in a
few years the sofa has started to
deteriorate so badly that it's no longer
functional it's uncomfortable and the
fold-out bed is jammed so I throw it out
its life was bound up with its functions
the assembly instructions were both part
of its life and part of mine and my
relation to the objects and habits
around me the sofa and its assembly are
bound up with what I do the other
objects and beings around me a culture
of domestic leisure 20th century design
imports junk and branding the
instructions are part of the life of the
sofa and have no sense or import beyond
the life of their fleeting purpose what
would it take to turn that sofa into art
well quite a lot you might say but one
can easily imagine an exhibition of 20th
century design where the object is taken
out of its world of function habit and
disposability that's my okay in order to
be art the object must succeed succeed
and surpass its own world instead of
something I throw out it's something
preserved as a sign of another world so
there have been serious challenges to
the art world's conception of art that
what I've just outlined that art is a
detached purposeless object freed from
the conditions of emergence but I want
to accept for now that definition
because I think it can tell us a lot
about the end of the world my hypothesis
is even though we've all taught students
or read essays about how that notion of
the detached art object is no longer
viable its displaced by notions of
installation aren't when
first century aesthetics I think it
still has an embedded purchase in the
attachment to our world so this is the
third part about the end of the world so
we've discussed ah now I'm going on to
the end of the world so there's a
current mania for the end of the world
evident in post-apocalyptic cinema
literature and other arts and also in a
series of theoretical and philosophical
endeavors including and I want to make a
lot of this the future of humanity
Institute at Oxford University I don't
for those of you who don't know it
there's a future of humanity Institute
at Oxford University
that is tasked with it has a couple of
REME its first task is thinking about
global catastrophic risk and the second
is an artificial intelligence project so
that the claim would be the the
interrelated claim that's embedded in
the remit is first that it's
catastrophic to lose a lot of humans
right that's catastrophic to lose a lot
of humans but it's not an existential
catastrophe what an existential
catastrophe would be to lose human
intelligence so one of the claims is
made that we might think that something
and I'm it is inflammatory but it's an
example that's used as we might think
the Holocaust is absolutely catastrophic
but really when all said and done we do
survive however losing intelligence
that's a real catastrophe now why I make
a lot of this is because there's
something about the human it's called
the future of humanity Institute which
is defined by not the existence of the
number of bodies but by a capacity to
think and so the artificial intelligence
project that is being explored at the
future of humanity Institute at Oxford
University is about saving and
developing and arriving at technological
maturity
of human intelligence and human
intelligence is defined as very narrowly
needless to say I could talk more about
that if you're interested so it does not
take much reflection I think to conclude
that the end of the world is the end of
our world no disaster scenarios
so from post-apocalyptic culture to
rarified institutes like the future of
humanity Institute survival is the
survival of a distilled version of what
we currently us and not just as we
currently are because that's not good
enough
but the distilled version where we've
hived off intelligence and benevolence
from the bit that's destroyed us so just
ask two scenarios frequently display
urban affluence globally attended by a
way of mass media reduced to the sorts
of conditions that most humans have been
living in and are still living in for
the sake of this world that is now
imagining its end so we don't need to
look at Mad Max fury fury road with its
depiction of humanity reduced to
resource depleted hordes terrorized by
squandering despots or Elysium with half
the world's population reduced to
indentured labor or colony television
series where life is haunted by the
constant surveillance undertaken by
invading and appropriating colonizers to
conclude that what we imagine as the end
of our world is humanity in general
experiencing life in the way that the
majority of humans already have so the
condition that Cormac MacCarthy figures
as the end of the world of mere
existence is not an exceptional horrific
future but the way most humans have
lived I say that quite literally as in
most humans have been tied to mere
existence such that and and such is the
limit of our imagination that any form
of existence other than our own is
deemed to be the end of the
world beyond cinema and literature
there's vast amounts work on
sustainability in the future that assume
that assumes that saving the planet
requires saving our world recycling
buying local driving a smaller car less
often purchasing carbon offsets or
having fewer children may or may not be
Knovel noble endeavors but they all
serve to sustain the notion that there
is our world and that it must be saved
indeed without the idea that this world
may fall back into fragility there would
not be and could not be the demand for
its continuity so I see post-apocalyptic
culture as having this ongoing
performative function of playing out our
n such that we demand our future
nothing is more capable of silencing the
question of whether and how we ought to
live than the continually replayed
possibility that we may not live and
this continually replayed scenario of
our non-being is not an affirmation of
the possibility of our end so much as
continuing in continuous insistence that
we must not end the cod judo of the 21st
century is not I think therefore I am
but rather I am threatened with
non-existence therefore I must continue
to be this is because non-existence or
the non-relational is not admissible in
our world and this is because we are the
world we are finally that moment in
human and life history that recognizes
itself as one humanity in variation to
lose a tribe or our people is lamentable
but to lose humanity is catastrophic so
here I would refer to there's a very
mournful Australian documentary called
the last tasmanian aborigine which is
very problematic for so many reasons
where there's a mournful attitude to
lost tribes it's mournful but it doesn't
have the catastrophic import of losing
humanity the implication being to lose
our true
or our people is different from losing
humanity because losing humanity is
losing us there is more than
parochialism at work here it's not just
that from within any world it would be
natural to want one's own world to
continue in fact I don't think there's
anything at all natural in the sense of
inevitable about the world and certainly
not about the end of the world so the
world that has the end of the world bent
built into it is this world that has
this very unique sense of the aesthetic
the only world that could be assessed
with obsessed with the end of the world
is the world that also harbours the art
world a world where I can view an object
as a fragment from a world that I can
read and view what sort of world can
take an object from another world set it
apart in a gallery and view it with
wonder what sort of world can have
industries devoted to the mass
production of copies where it's possible
to view and own for oneself an object
that one values from afar what sort of
world teaches global literature's it's a
world that is so bound up with a very
specific sense of the world that it
relies upon other worlds and therefore
cannot imagine anything other than
itself consider the scenarios through
which we imagine the end of the world
ranging from the classic scene in the
Planet of the Apes where Charlton Heston
the first Planet of the Apes Charlton
Heston views a statue of liberty that is
reduced to so much junk to the Book of
Eli where there's one remaining copy of
the Bible but unfortunately it's in
Braille to oblivion where Tom Cruise
holds on to an LP of whiter shade of
pale to emily Sinjin mantle station 11
where a wandering troupe continue to
perform Shakespeare and to travel to the
Museum of humanity that once was these
scenes I want to argue aren't simply
dystopias they are displacements of
things we hold dear the Statue of
Liberty Shakespeare a whiter shade of
pale if we do hold that dear their
displacements of things we hold dear to
a world in which they may know
longer be recognized as having any value
or sense right so it's this horrific
image that there's a Bible but it's in
Braille and no one wants to read it or
can read it so it's a that's the end of
the world when the philosopher Martin
Heidegger said animals were poor in
world he did not deprive them of a world
but set them apart in their poverty
animals have habits expectations
memories and even basic forms of
sociality what they don't have is a
capacity for the end of the world or a
capacity for angst to experience their
will as our world as though all the
rhythms and manners that composed its
existence might be otherwise humans not
only have a world but in their capacity
to be capacity to be bored or anxious
can experience their own world as if it
were no longer
so for Heidegger one of the ways this
world of the world could be experienced
was through art and through thinking in
the age of the world picture Heidegger
makes a contrast between the
managerialism of the present everyone
with their own expertise and range of
things and thinking where any world of
things intimates other worlds so I'm
using this concept from Heidegger's
critically right I'm saying that he has
this highly so if the animal is poor in
well then it's good to be rich in world
or to be human is to be designers to be
rich in world such a world are well
blessed with a sense of itself because
of other worlds is always implicitly the
art world this is to say that the art
world is bound up with a self-defining
project of humanity that is both
colonizing and productive of a form of
leisured viewing that requires many
other laboring and appropriated worlds
more importantly the world that now
plays its own impossible and over and
over again is coterminous with an art
world attitude so for all its some low
culture take over post-apocalyptic
culture even films like the
davia Stood Still the day after tomorrow
they're actually obsessed with a really
traditional notion of art that is
without these things that we hold and
value and observe from afar it might as
well be the end of the world in a
standard post apocalyptic narrative
something designated as humanity is
threatened and we just and we know just
what this humanity is because of what
would remain mere life right so there's
always this war in post-apocalyptic
culture between humans as they are with
their cultural paraphernalia and humans
as they must not be humans reduced to
mere life one more example Chris Nolan's
interstellar for all its complexity
Pitts ABBA knighted humanity blessed
with imagination and Futurity against a
merely survivalist bureaucracy so
interstellar has a managerial human
world in which mere survival is the only
value and the and the hero of the film
is Matthew McConaughey who's an
astronaut right who risks his life in
order to you know once more embrace
frontier spirit through and he
represents sort of imagination and
Futurity so the central character an
astronaut must travel frontier spirit
style to save us all and it's only by
being presented as the possible sufferer
of loss that the narrative impulse
allows this fighting and colonizing
humanity to be the only humanity of the
future now not all post apocalyptic
dramas are interstellar and are often
more allegorical about the logic of
colonization that is at the same time a
logic of art so put more succinctly all
post-apocalyptic films are also films
about colonization it's about a portion
of humanity seizing hold at the future a
portion of humanity that's at once
destroyed the world but deems itself to
be the only humanity that can save the
world
so let's imagine the media rich affluent
stable and urban world of Matt Manhattan
about to be wiped out by a vie
climate catastrophe or invasion
sometimes the threat is humanity itself
in the form of terrorism or planet
destroying capitalism but it's precisely
by way of posing itself as threatened
that one can then proceed with a
necessary logic of redemption the more
exposed fragile vulnerable and damaged
this future is imagined to be the more
forceful the heroic narrative of
salvation one might just say that this
is one world urban Western capitalist
global contemplating and averting its
own end one might see this in Freudian
terms not only that one plays out trauma
in advance as a form of mastery but also
as a reaction formation where the more
fragile we are the more we insist that
we will and must survive all that may be
going on but I want to argue that
there's more at play the way we value
this world that has a sense of other
worlds is telling if humans were nothing
more than existing here and now no
longer blessed with libraries and an
industry of the humanities that can
purvey and convey other worlds they
would not be truly human so I'm speaking
as it were here there's a normative
definition of the human that has been
tied to unthinkable 'ti if there's no
libraries there's no archive then
there's no world to be human is to be
rich in world and to be rich in world
requires conceptually materially
geopolitically and existentially other
worlds so the end of the world is the
end of the human being who's always been
able to view and trade in other worlds
so there's a logic of fragility at the
heart of the object that is also at the
heart of the art world that tells us a
lot about the end of the world in order
for a work to be read viewed sold
circulated and saved it must take on a
material form right in order for an
artwork to survive it has to be given
into some form of body or matter we
can't read something into the future
unless it's survives even in digital
form it must therefore be detached from
its first world if it ever had one
so what allows the artwork to survive is
a materiality that also exposes it to
fragility in order for something to
survive it has to take on a form but if
it takes on that form it's also exposed
to fragility this doesn't change with
digital art on the contrary one can
imagine a future in which because of
digital technologies Shakespeare and
Goethe still exist but that very
material continuity does not secure
survival so the two points I want to
make in relation to this is the more
that we store works right the more we
have the tendency not to read them this
is supposedly the problem of the
Internet right the more knowledge you
have online the less you actually want
to secure it or keep it keep it in an
archive but I also want to make a claim
about the the distinct relationship
between art science and materiality see
if anyone will harangue me about this
but once it's a genre claim once a
scientific or mathematical truth is
articulated it can survive the
destruction of its origin right it the
history of mathematics might be
interesting but we don't need to know it
in order to be mathematicians we don't
need those original texts we might want
to be able to go back to the original
proofs and and and so on but the actual
sense can be detached from its material
origin I think it's safe to say that if
all the copies of Shakespeare will wiped
out but I could still tell you the story
of Hamlet that we wouldn't say
Shakespeare it survived oh it's okay I
can I can give you a catch up I know I
know the story I know the plot right
there's something and that the and
that's a that spectrum between like
keeping the original engravings of plate
of Blake's poetry to the pure theorems
of logic obviously there's a threshold
of indifference
but it's exactly but it's that logic of
art that the the artwork survives
because it's attached to a materiality
which also exposes it to K to decay but
that very material continuity doesn't
secure survival so a lot of
post-apocalyptic works show the Statue
of Liberty but no one recognizes it's
the Statue of Liberty right that's the
the horror that the world exists but
doesn't no one knows it's the world this
is my last paragraph just in case you're
flagging so works the one of the
possibilities at the end of the world is
that works could exist as so much waste
and rubble so I take us iconic that
scene from Planet of the Apes where the
Statue of Liberty's exists but no one
knows it's the Statue of Liberty right
that's the end of the world the world
exists humans exist but they don't know
they're human anymore right there's no
art there's no globalism there's no
screens there's no reading there's no
communication there's no relationality
in any rich sense we're living from
moment to moment mouthful from to mouth
or so works could exist as so much work
waste and rubble they are art only in
beginning in being given a form beyond
their world so that's what makes them
art that they can be detached from the
world but they can only be sustained as
art by intimating a world right the
Statue of Liberty that's strewn on the
beach and the plunder is that art you
know the whole point about Duchamp isn't
it is that art becomes what it is and
being detached and and viewed this odd
play of the art industry art history and
art criticism relied upon thinking of
things as bound up with worlds and a
world that is capable of reading and
appreciating these worlds in this sense
imagining a world without art is
imagining the end of the world that's my
claim about post-apocalyptic culture
that the end of the world is the end the
end of the aesthetic the end of art only
a world that has a sense of its specific
end can also demand that it must not end
it's too big to fail cultures tribes
languages and worlds they
can all come and go but the world that
has a sense of both cultures tribes
languages that's too big to fail we can
lose a tribe but we can't lose the sense
of the world that views those tribes
only a world that can look on other
worlds as world less can regard itself
as the world so only a world that can
read Cormac McCarthy's the road as the
end of the world that's the world right
the world in Cormac McCarthy's the road
is just our world or the end of the
world only a world that manufactured art
and the humanities by stabilizing its
means of existence and stabilizing its
modes of existence through the arts
could generate a concept of humanity so
global and completing that it produces
the impossibility of the outside by
constantly imagining the outside it
produces the impossibility of its own
outside by constantly imagining the
outside Humanity in this sense is too
big to fail thank you
[Applause]
moderate okay no that's fine I'm
prepared to moderate as yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
yeah yeah and I the I'm gonna refer to
year of the flood just to and I I think
if I had to do what literary critics do
and then get my theory and say look
here's a writer that's saying what I'm
saying I would choose Margaret Atwood
because I think there's an on-going
critique in her work of the creation of
something that must endure right that
has the blueprint the expression and
blueprint of the self right that must
survive and to give you a concrete
example from year of the
the narrator I think it's Ren refers to
her her her friend Amanda who's an
artist who creates but draws honey on
the floor and then ants I mean this is
not clearly I haven't memorized the text
right so and and the work comes and goes
in it decays right so there's this
notion and I think it's tied to at words
theory I mean everything I've read seems
to suggest that I'm misreading it but
this is how I read her that she's got
this notion of instead of a former
biological kinship that wants to enjoy
and instead of a form of art practice or
or bio politics because that whole
trilogy is about bio but like managing
life securing life owning life which is
I why I read the Adamic you know eco
people I drink that is completely ironic
that they're just they're just as
controlling of life right and it's
continuity and then she has these
fleeting moments of female characters
who don't reproduce biologically but
they make friendships right so it's a
bit Donna Haraway is make what is it
kiss not Ken better not get that get
that the wrong way around and and and
there's this notion of a creativity that
would be fleeting right and it's a sort
but when you think about it that's the
way that's what I meant by like when we
take objects right and and they must
endure right and that they have this
lineage attached to them so we could get
into a long discussion about what's
going on with like blade but it's the
secure Blade Runner but it is about the
securing of replication right well and
that's it so I think that the the I
gotta like I've been writing a lot about
living works of art because I'm
interested in Milton Wright the poet my
dogs also called Milton so I always feel
I have to
just because that doesn't matter but
when I say Milton it subtly adds no I'm
talking about the poet and in
Areopagitica he says well it's actually
more murderous to murder an individual
than murder a book because when you
murder a book you kill something that
will live on right now that's
interesting because there's this notion
that the artwork and I think it's in I
mean it's not just in milkman see all
through Milton when he writes on
Shakespeare we don't really sister
Shakespeare we don't really need copies
of Shakespeare because your words are
eternal that's right so I think there is
this notion that you want the work of
art to be alive like hyper alive because
then you have this notion of humanity as
not what will decay when these things
decay right you want this humanity has
to be bigger than all the books it
creates right so it's it's a paradoxical
logic and and I think Blade Runner
I'm not a Blade Runner I know there are
played runner schools but it's playing
it's playing out with that notion if you
want it to be alive and survive and
enjoy but right not so alive that it
starts to take over and that's always
that's the problem also people like
Milton have with books right they want
freedom of the press they want
circulation but they all smell tan also
believed but if you do that enough
ultimately truth will write because it's
a wife it's an always a proper life
right I think Milton hadn't read any
Baudrillard he didn't think that the
copy of the book that he was going to
say was going to mutate into something
yeah yes so I think I think we want it
to be alive right but not but a certain
for organic life in a well bounded form
not a viral form of life yeah
yes oh okay yeah right
I think that that bit of my ideas to
speak self importantly is really quite
simple which is there's been a history
of a portion of humanity stabilizing
itself by outsourcing fragility that's I
think uncontroversial right so
particularly if you're like white
Australian you have lived you live in a
desert landscape right it's become and
you've imported European culture there
right massively destructive for other
humans right then when that culture when
that world begins to decay right you've
made this absolutely robust stable world
right where you think climb I'm not a
climate change denier right but you
stabilize the climate so our notion of
climate is actually manufactured we
stabilized it and we stabilized that by
making by by either outsourcing
instability right or what do you call it
when you bet bet on it hedge it into the
future right
you've deferred your instability right
so the reason why things are volatile
now is because we've had stability so
what and then it's and then we imagine
that fragility right the state of
emergency is an interruption to what is
properly human and I want to reverse
that and I want to say that what we've
taken to be properly human stable right
is actually always occurred by the
things that we are now fearing being
manufactured elsewhere so my take on
fragility is
because we're so married to robust
invulnerability that's why I use the
phrase too big to fail one can't imagine
a human life other than ours as anything
other than the end of the world alright
so yes does that maybe make it clear yes
read the book
yeah out by Christmas yeah big stocking
filler yeah right as I I I find the
zombie problem a very simple and
unfasten eighty one and there's a a long
sort of philosophical debate in
Australian analytic philosophy right
about and it doesn't so much use the
zombie but if I'm having all the
perceptions movements actions that would
count as personhood right but I don't
have the interior already am i a person
so and then you know that creates now it
seems to me the very fact that we have
as a problem right if I if I look like a
person touch like a person talk like a
person seem to act like a person but I'm
not that shows we've got a long history
of manufacturing interior 'ti right but
the guarantees and sets apart a type of
experience right that mean in this
seminar we had this afternoon this is
the counter the sort of other end of the
spectrum the amount of literature I've
read that celebrates for example
Buddhism right mindfulness because
instead of me monitoring you know I've
got to win this tennis match because if
I don't win this tennis match you know
then I'll lose prestige and others
prostrate instead of that this whole
notion of just being in the moment being
present right if you if you look at that
naive literature on Buddhism it's
actually a sort of valorisation of what
we imagine zombies to be right a pure
present nurse that doesn't want to and I
if there are any Buddhists in the room
I'm not calling you zombies but or if
there any zombies in the room I'm not
attributing a religion to you that you
may not want to buy into but what I'm
saying is this is sort of thought
experiment of of mindlessness right the
horror is the zombie and the law is the
infant or the animal or the Buddhist
right and so I but but getting back to
you no you're right there's now zombies
zombie zombies are chasing you the
running at that you can do yeah I just
think that uh the reason why it's got
like a lot of recent purchase is because
there's this time in there's all these
things about zombie capitalism but we
are dealing with we're here we're alive
we're humans but what we've known and
valued as human is up for grabs right so
if we look at the new forms of attention
and reading and spectatorship that we
are embarking on those old forms of
memory cognition and archive right then
no longer then no longer prima facie
valuable right I think we here in this
room right would be horrified at a world
in which there wasn't books and reading
but I think there's many humans who
don't feel the horror of that and so I
think you know zombie-ism is I'm not
saying that people that don't read is on
these right but I am saying that we lock
and look at people who don't read is on
right they might as well be zombies so
that's where I see zombie mania coming
from a sort of fascination with like
being mindless right mere life mere
existence Cormac McCarthy's the road
they're not they're not zombies right
but they're there although they are not
there as the laws would say becoming
zombie right they're on their way right
there to lose your humanity is to lose
that sense of of that richer sense of
temporality and Futurity yes yes yes yes
can't imagine Enya is continually
imagining right so that's why I actually
think the end of the world films and
literature a lot of them aren't really
about the end of the world right they
they use things like so take Blade
Runner or they use climate changes the
narrative preface right oh the reason
why we got to this stage is some
corporation managed to synthesize life
right but organics
managed to synthesize farming methods
right so if there is a preface it's not
about the end of the world that we're
real it's about the end of this let's
call it Western affluent liberal
readerly world right and so and I think
you know then
could diagnose and say that well why why
are we panicking about that when we
really should be panicking about the
mole dive sinking or Miami sinking right
but it's what I think then this this
sort of parochial attachment what what
that's why I say we can we're happy to
lose a tribe and when I say that you
know I don't mean I'm happy to but we do
see the people and we lament it right
but that doesn't have these sort of
existential catastrophe and what we're
not we're what we're not worried about
losing the human species right because
Cormac McCarthy's right still got but so
I think that you're right we're not if
we really were in the end of the world
we wouldn't be looking at the Statue of
Liberty and crying right we'd be looking
at the and you know suffering humans and
crying so I think that the I guess you
know one of my shorter claims is that
all that end of the world literature is
actually shut you know disclosed Avars
or what we've inscribed to matter to us
and it's not human life right and and
fur gotta feel like I'm attached to the
archive right
it's so not Porto Rico right it's it's
the archive and that's why I mean meant
to see the end of the world as the end
of Manhattan is spectacular but is more
than that right it's it's yeah it was
yeah
yeah I mean you you would have to say it
has a notion of the of the art objects
signifying a lost past world right
that's that's how it functions again in
Blade Runner right there's a there's a
little wooden horse that signifies
Paradise Lost right and then you have to
make the good old Multan ik maneuver
that is without a sense of a lost world
right
we don't have who we are and that might
that's not just melt on ik that's every
disaster epic has to have these bad
humans took over right the capitalists
the Americans what you know like it has
to be some accident that occurred that
allowed evil neoliberal bio corporate
humanity to take over but the real
humanity is
there because otherwise we can't say oh
we just want to save the way we are now
that's not going to fly right we've
we've messed up the planet we can't say
humanity has a prima facie right to
survive what we can do is have by way of
the lost object right the proper
humanity that was somehow displaced or
pushed away by Satan or capitalism right
and that lost object is a sign of our
proper potentiality that's that's as
true of Battlestar Galactica as it is of
a gamblin or Burnitz Stiegler right his
work on editing right now has you know
that that archive without that archive
we're nothing right and and yes so
that's yeah yes soldiers you probably
know this in which grief is triggered by
arbitrary objects just because it's so
difficult to empathize with such kind of
strong things so it's empathy of the
inorganic is easier than empathy
yeah yes because I think if we go back
to what we want to save I think this is
this is an answer what we want to save
even in these very parochial gung-ho Pro
Manhattanville right what we want to
save is never what we are right it's
never it's it's this lost enigmatic
humanity that was somehow given in the
form of the child yes yes so I think
that it's always more catastrophic I
mean that's where one of the questions
that came up in the seminar we did this
afternoon was like the the are wise they
know art about the loss of 9/11 and I
think there there is because on the one
hand 9/11 had this odd category we do
have these disasters like the mass
shooting yesterday and we feel we feel
mournful about them but they don't have
that catastrophic grief-stricken sense
of this imagined lost world and I think
the interesting thing about 9/11 it was
both it was both an actual loss of life
that was also a symbolic you know
theatrical that was the genius if you
like of the Terrorism behind it right
that it wasn't just killing a lot of
people but killing something more than
that so I think that that interesting
thing there's a quote not so good as
Walter Benjamin but where Hume says it's
not contrary to reason to avoid the
scratch on a scratch on my little finger
over the destruction of humanity right
and he's making this claim he's making
this claim about the poverty of reason
right but I think he's on to something
more about the problem of empathy right
and an immediacy and something as
abstract as losing humanity doesn't have
that fragmentary attachment that we
would have to partial partial objects
yes so it got from benjamine to Hume get
things out of
to Scotland I think it's always my
theoretical yes right so this is human
creation of some boundary where we just
you know say turning comes after that as
a way of not having to engage right yeah
so to let what we're what we're
experiencing now is just another right
sure I think um I think I'd like I know
I disagree with that because because I
used to think it right and I had a grad
student so this is where it started so
that the the things that made me
dislodge me from what I was interested
in was originally just it's called
post-apocalyptic culture right and I'm
not so myopic to think that it began in
the 21st century because it says
post-apocalyptic write an apocalypse
gives you an indication and you know I I
spent a lot of time reading Blake who's
you know imagining ends of worlds and so
forth but then this is why I want to
make a difference between the end of the
world
and the end of the world right so that
what you see and it came from a graduate
student who was a MIDI ablest and the
thing is because I'm Australian I've not
read any medieval literature and I know
what MIDI ablest do is no matter what
you're talking about they've read
something that's like 20 steps ahead of
it and you can't go back and read it
because you're not a medieval it so you
have to take their word for it but my
grad student said well you know and this
made sense to me all the time these
people were living with us
so they're here we might all be wiped
out tomorrow no it was at the end of the
world right these play a plague might
just wipe us out and then another friend
of mine who was working on indigenous
Australian narratives they all had
narratives of yeah there was this there
were these people that exist and they
don't exist oh right and we might not we
might not exist right but what I want to
draw a an essential distinction is
between what you're saying which is yeah
there's often being narratives or
thoughts of non-existence right I pocket
the apocalyptic tradition in Christian
and Beyond Christian thinking and then
this very very fetishized sense of the
end of the world which isn't as
imaginative as Blake right where you get
a huge configuration and and from you
know spectacular revelation that's not a
revelation instead you get people
wandering around Manhattan that don't
have television anymore
right so that if you if you look at and
I always get the names of the two not
the daily Oh stood the day after
tomorrow right which is the end of the
world set in the New York Public Library
I think that's yeah it's not that so the
de leus that still is the one with Keanu
Reeves with the only and that's the end
of the world isn't this what you're
suggesting humans in their capacity to
have these metaphysical imaginings about
non-being I'm with you there right this
is the opposite of that this is not you
know the industry we're in now is
actually incapable of imagining what
might it be not to be right instead it's
what might it be to live like a lot of
humans already live all right I mean I
think I'm really interested in Cormac
McCarthy like Margaret out would write
because I think they're both onto the
fact that the end of the world already
exists
it's just else we've just pushed it to
mix from McCormick McCarthy it's Mexico
right and I think he's Mexico is not
Mexico that makes
right this invented place where that's
all that's already the road right you're
not convinced correctly start expanding
yeah yeah we have a certain view of the
world right now in our world yeah no I
I'm with you 100% on that my claim is
that the sorts of thoughts experience
that you're entertaining there right I
think and I want to make this quite
concrete about the politics of
sustainability and climate change and
the environment we imagine right that
although we keep going in some modified
version of what we have now or nothing
right and what I think needs to be done
is not look at let's go back to Cormac
McCarthy not look at Mexico as the end
of the world right not look at lives
that are other than ours as well it
might as well be the end of the world
right that I think there needs to be
more of the sort of imaginative late
right would this you know what what
other forms of human existence are
imaginable and we don't just say well I
might as well be the end of the world
right if there's no TV I mean that's a
lot of this post-apocalyptic culture is
a world that's just no longer urban
affluent Manhattan all right and I think
there might be other forms of existence
that are viable yeah
maybe maybe thank you
[Applause]
[Music]